la nuit il se passe tout un tas de
choses dont on se rappelle pas forcément
quand on se réveille comme le
somnambulisme ou l'apnée du sommeil par
exemple ou plein d'autres trucs mais
c'est pas le sujet et ma figurez-vous
qu'aujourd'hui on va parler de rien de
tout ça on va parler d'un autre truc
qu'on peut faire sans le savoir surtout
si on dort seul ou avec quelqu'un qui
veut pas nous vexer mais qui peut avoir
des conséquences sur la santé grincer
des dents et promis cette vidéo est
garantie 100% sans bruit de grincement
dedans
[Musique]
alors on va voir tout de suite tout ce
qu'il faut savoir sur les grincements de
temps alors on va voir tout de suite
tout ce qu'il faut savoir sur les
grincements dedans la grenace Mont d'Or
alors on va voir tout de suite tout ce
qu'il faut savoir sur les grincements
dans la nuit
alors on va voir tout de suite tout ce
qu'il faut savoir sur les grincements
dans la nuit mais avant ça pour que vos
nuits soient douces quand même
laissez-moi vous parler d'un truc cette
vidéo est sponsorisée par Emma oui cela
même qui avait déjà sponsorisé ma vidéo
sur la paralysie du sommeil il faut
consulter avant que ça devienne
insupportable les boules shit sur le
sommeil la bonne gerbe des familles ou
le contrôle des rêves c'est triple raté
en fait on change pas une équipe qui
gagne donc normalement vous les
connaissez mais je vous rappelle quand
même ce qu'ils font et qui sont ils
vendent des matelas
n'est pas seulement
ivanent aussi du linge de lit moi j'en
ai par exemple des oreillers à mémoire
de forme des couettes des sur-matelas à
mémoire de forme moi j'ai les trois ils
vendent plein de trucs pour améliorer la
qualité de votre sommeil et la mienne du
coup et celle de ma fille
oui parce que j'ai pris un matelas pour
ma fille un matelas hybride il a été élu
meilleur choix UFC Que Choisir en 2021
fallait bien ça c'est ma fille quand
même prunelle de mes yeux tout ça ils
font aussi le ma original original le
plus vendu en France depuis deux ans et
en plus ils sont garantis 10 ans alors
vous allez me dire ok moi j'ai envie
d'avoir un matelas cool mais c'est pas
facile à transporter quand même oui vous
avez cette voix là et ben pas de souci
parce que il livre gratuitement en 72
heures et si ça vous plaît pas le retour
est gratuit aussi en fait vous avez
s'ennuie d'essai sans risque c'est à
dire que vous avez trois mois pour
renvoyer tout ça gratuitement si vous
n'êtes pas convaincu en plus en ce
moment c'est Black Friday chez Emma
c'est leur meilleur offre de l'année
donc si vous avez envie de commander un
nouveau matelas des draps des
accessoires tout ce que vous voulez vous
avez moins 10% sur tout le site avec le
code
DTC et vous connaissez maintenant c'est
10% de réduction en plus des réductions
du Black Friday sur le site le code est
valable six mois donc c'est bon jusqu'à
début mai 2023 tout est dans la
description de la vidéo vous avez juste
à cliquer sur le lien à passer commande
et Go vous vous souvenez il y a quelques
temps maintenant on s'était demandé
pourquoi on claque des dents quand On a
Froid oui on fait plein de trucs avec
nos dents alors qu'à la base c'est pas
du tout à ça qu'elle devrait servir
alors donc claquer des dents maintenant
on connaît mais grincer des dents
et bah déjà grincer des dents quand on
dort ça s'appelle du bruxisme attention
le bruxisme ça peut être deux choses
soit grincer des dents soit juste les
serrer très fort mais sans mouvement
latéral donc ça fait pas de bruit c'est
embêtant quand même vous allez voir mais
au moins ça fait pas de bruit le
bruxisme c'est une hyperactivité des
muscles mendicateurs
c'est les muscles qui servent à la
manducation
OK et la manducation c'est une série de
trucs qu'on fait pour préparer ce qu'on
mange à être digéré c'est-à-dire choper
la bouffe la déplacer dans notre bouche
pour bien la mélanger à notre salive et
puis mâcher
notamment avec nos mâchoires le
maxillaire supérieur qui bouge pas et le
maxillaire inférieur qu'on appelle aussi
mandibule et qui est mobile et donc
parfois les muscles qui commandent nos
mâchoires bah ils se mettent à faire
leur vie tout seul et à se contracter
sans qu'on leur demande rien parmi ces
muscles il y en a un qui s'appelle le
Massey terre
[Musique]
le master
oui bon donc il y a un muscle qui
s'appelle comme ça là et son rôle c'est
de faire monter l'amandibule pour fermer
la bouche
pour serrer les dents quoi et il joue
aussi un rôle dans les fameux mouvements
latéraux ce qui font grincer les dents
le problème c'est que ce muscle il est
très puissant il peut exercer une
pression jusqu'à 58 kg par centimètre
carré alors c'est pas le muscle le plus
puissant de notre corps le muscle le
plus puissant de notre corps c'est le
grand glutéal
le grand fessier quoi donc oui dans
l'absolu vous pouvez mordre plus fort
avec vos fesses qu'avec votre bouche
sauf que bah vous avez pas dedans dans
le long que ça ferait moins mal pas du
tout ça dont je veux parler qu'est-ce
que je raconte moi donc ce muscle il est
très puissant je parle du masséter ah ça
le fait plus
donc ce muscle
il est très puissant et vous imaginez
bien que le fait qu'il se contracte
comme ça tout le temps bah ça finit par
avoir des conséquences au niveau des
dents déjà vous vous doutez bien les
serrer les frotter les unes contre les
autres à force ça les abîme ça peut
aller d'une simple usure jusqu'à la
destruction de l'émail et donc des
problèmes de danse sensible voire
carrément des fractures des fractures
dentaires déjà rien que ça c'est pas ouf
et vous remarquerez que de la même
manière que je vous ai épargné les
bruits de grincement dedans je vous ai
aussi épargné les images je suis quand
même super sympa les dents elles peuvent
aussi se déchausser ça peut jouer sur
les gencives mais les conséquences elles
peuvent aller au-delà de ça ne serait-ce
que parce qu'avoir des dents en mauvais
état ça peut donner des parodontites et
que ça ça peut avoir des répercussions
bien au-delà de votre bouche on en avait
déjà parlé dans une vidéo n'hésitez pas
à retourner la voir un petit rappel
là-dessus ça fait jamais de mal mais il
y a aussi tout ce qui concerne les
douleurs par exemple évidemment les
muscles en question à force ils
finissent par être douloureux mais comme
c'est toute cette zone là qui est sur
sollicitée ça peut aussi donner des
douleurs qui remontent jusque dans les
oreilles je sais pas si vous connaissez
les douleurs dans les oreilles mais
c'est un peu comme les maux dedans ça
fait pas envie ça peut même aller
jusqu'à provoquer des maux de tête
chroniques pas des migraines on en a
déjà parlé ici aussi les migraines c'est
un truc bien particulier dans des maux
de tête chroniques personne n'a envie de
ça non plus la mandibule on a dit elle
bouge pour qu'un os bouge en général il
faut qu'il y ait une articulation dans
un coin en l'occurrence là c'est
l'articulation temporo mandibulaire
c'est l'endroit où l'amandibule
s'articule sur l'os temporal cet
articulation à force d'être surchargée
bah elle finit par morfler ça donne des
douleurs et des crampes quand on la
sollicite genre quand on ouvre grand la
bouche pour bâiller par exemple ou parce
qu'on aime bien ouvrir très grand sa
bouche ça arrive aussi mais parfois
c'est aussi juste comme ça au repos et
dans les cas les plus avancés
l'articulation elle peut même finir par
ne plus fonctionner correctement et
quand on sait qu'on s'en sert pour
manger pour parler et pour plein
d'autres trucs bah on se rend compte que
ça peut vite devenir handicapant et puis
au niveau musculaire en plus des
douleurs qu'est-ce qui arrive à un
muscle qu'on fait trop travailler
il gonfle on appelle ça une hypertrophie
alors quand c'est harmonieux sur tout le
corps on aime ou on n'aime pas mais
quand c'est juste les muscles qu'on a là
sur le côté des joues
bon donc tout ça c'est pénible et encore
je vous ai pas parlé des répercussions
que ça a sur la qualité de notre sommeil
mais alors pourquoi on fait ça pourquoi
on grince des dents comme ça on dormant
et bah à vrai dire il peut y avoir
plusieurs explications et vous allez
voir que comme d'habitude dans ces
cas-là on a plein de bout d'explications
mais le mécanisme il reste mal connu par
exemple on considère qu'il y a des
formes de bruxisme qu'on appelle les
formes de bruxisme primaires qui ne sont
liées à aucune cause médicale et des
formes secondaires qui sont liées à des
maladies neurologiques ou psychiatriques
par exemple ou à la prise de certains
médicaments ou certaines drogues et on
considère que certaines formes primaires
sont ce qu'on appelle
idiopathiques alors idiopathique c'est
un de mes mots préféré parce que c'est
un mot qui claque bien qui est bien
jargon et tout alors qu'en fait ça veut
juste dire qu'on ne connaît pas la cause
on sait pas quoi mais bon il y a un
certain nombre de choses qu'on sait
quand même d'abord on sait que le
système nerveux central est impliqué
c'est logique quand on y pense parce que
nos nerfs c'est ce qui contrôle nos
muscles donc quand ça foire à ce niveau
là on a des contractions musculaires
incontrôlées on sait aussi que certains
neurotransmetteurs c'est à dire les
substances qui permettent de transmettre
le message de neurones en euros joue un
rôle dans le déclenchement du brexit
c'est neurotransmetteur comme la
sérotonine par exemple ou des
catécholamines comme la dopamine ou la
noradrénaline je sais pas si vous en
avez déjà entendu parler et ben il joue
aussi un rôle dans le système du plaisir
et de la récompense et il se trouve que
certaines drogues comme la cocaïne ou la
MDMA par exemple et ben elle bloque leur
recapture d'ailleurs leur réabsorption
si vous voulez et du coup comme ils sont
pas réabsorbés leur taux ils montent ils
montent et ils deviennent beaucoup plus
élevés que d'habitude plus de plaisir
mais plus de bruxisme aussi ce qu'on
sait aussi parce que des chercheurs ont
mesuré tout ça c'est que les épisodes de
bruxisme
icoïcident avec une augmentation de
l'activité cardiaque et de l'activité
cérébrale et qu'ils apparaissent
essentiellement pendant des phases de
micro-réveil au cours du sommeil lent
léger je sais pas si vous vous rappelez
bien des différentes phases de sommeil
je vais pas vous refaire le topo mais je
vous mets les liens dans la description
comme d'hab et puis on sait que les
troubles du sommeil favorisent aussi le
bruxisme
c'est le serpent qui se mord ce qu'on
sait encore c'est qu'il y a plus de
Bruxelles parmi les gens qui respirent
par la bouche en dormant oui boxeur
c'est un vrai mot on peut dire bruxsoman
aussi
le bruxisme c'est parfois appelé la
brume somanie bref pourquoi on
grincerait des dents en dormant parce
qu'on respire la bouche ouverte il y a
une hypothèse à ce sujet le fait de
respirer par la bouche la nuit ça
assèche les voies aériennes supérieures
c'est à dire essentiellement la bouche
et la gorge vous le savez sûrement déjà
d'ailleurs si c'est votre cas parce que
vous vous réveillez souvent avec la
bonne pâteuse et la laine d'un candidat
à Koh-Lanta et est-ce que vous vous
souvenez ce qu'on a dit tout à l'heure
sur la manducation la mastication ça
stimule la production de salive parce
que l'organisme pense qu'on est en train
de manger et qui va falloir imprégner
des aliments de salive pour les préparer
à digérer donc quand on grince des dents
la nuit on fait du herbrofing si vous
voulez pour feinter notre propre
organisme et le pousser à produire de la
salive tout ça dans le seul but
d'humidifier notre bouche et notre gorge
qui sont un peu sèches astucieux et ce
serait pareil pour les gens qui ont un
reflux gastro-œsophagien c'est quand on
a des remontées acides de l'estomac en
gros ça irrite un petit la zone et la
salive elle est censée venir lubrifier
tout ça dans un même ordre d'idée on
sait que les gens qui font de l'apnée du
sommeil grincent plus des dents aussi là
c'est pareil il y a des hypothèses mais
rien de vraiment prouver
scientifiquement quand on fait de
l'apnée du sommeil les voies
respiratoires elles se ferment et ça
fait augmenter la pression au niveau des
oreilles notamment parce que tout ça ça
communique et on suppose que déclencher
des mouvements de mastication comme ça
ça pourrait être une tentative de
déboucher tout ça un peu comme quand
vous prenez un chewing-gum en avion
d'ailleurs on a remarqué que les enfants
qui grincent des dents en dormant bah
ils le font beaucoup moins une fois
qu'on leur a retiré les amygdales ou les
végétations parce que c'est aussi des
trucs qui bouche et qui font augmenter
la pression bon on dit aussi qu'avoir
les dents à la lignée ou avoir eu un
traumatisme au niveau des articulations
dans la zone ou des cervicales ça
pourrait entraîner un bruxisme donc vous
voyez comme bien souvent dans ces cas-là
quand on sait pas trop on a des pistes
on a des hypothèses mais bon
l'apnée du sommeil et le reflux
gastro-œsophagien est-ce que ça provoque
le bruxisme ou est-ce que c'est une même
cause qui provoque les deux on est pas
trop sûr par contre il y a un truc là on
est sûr que ça favorise le brexit et on
sait même que c'est pour ça que le
nombre de cas étant très net
augmentation dans un certain nombre de
pays depuis ces dernières années et
notamment depuis la pandémie et ce truc
c'est
non c'est pas le covid c'est
le stress d'ailleurs le stress c'est une
des causes qui donne aussi un bruxisme
diurne un bruxisme la journée juste à
part de très rares exceptions la journée
en général on grince pas des dents on a
juste les mâchoires très contractées
mais ça peut quand même avoir les
conséquences dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure alors pour éviter tout ça
justement qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire et
bah il y a pas mal de choses qu'on peut
faire pour éviter les problèmes et
notamment les gouttières essayez
d'emporter au début ça fait un peu bavé
vous allez vite comprendre pourquoi on
appelle ça comme ça
ça empêche pas vraiment de grands CD
dents encore que à terme ça peut finir
par aider mais en tout cas ça évite de
se les abîmer et il y en a même qu'on
peut porter la journée sans que ça se
voit ça se fait chez le dentiste donc
n'hésitez pas à prendre rendez-vous si
vous vous rendez compte que vous vous
lancez des dents en plus ça vous
permettra de faire un petit check up
pour voir si c'est pas trop abîmé
là-dedans dans la série des trucs qui
empêchent pas de grincer des dents mais
qui soulage quand même et c'est déjà pas
mal il y a aussi les massages on l'a dit
tout à l'heure si vous grincez beaucoup
des dents la nuit c'est possible que
vous vous réveillez avec des douleurs
musculaires là sur le côté et bah il y a
des techniques de massage spécifiques je
vous mets tout ça ou vous savez
dans la description il y a tout un tas
de traitement possible ça dépend
évidemment de la cause si on en trouve
une il y en a un qui propose des
injections de toxines botulique de Botox
en fait dans les muscles concernés pour
les empêcher de trop se contracter
quoi qu'il en soit si vous grincez des
dents et que ça vous pose des problèmes
oui parce que heureusement c'est quand
même pas toujours le cas parlez-en à
votre médecin et à votre dentiste donc
il vous orienteront vers le traitement
qui vous convient le mieux alors petit
truc que vous pouvez faire comme ça tout
seul de votre côté a priori le fait de
dormir sur le dos ça favoriserait
l'activité des muscles de la mastication
bon à vrai dire dormir sur le ventre ce
serait pas ouf non plus donc l'idéal ce
serait de dormir sur le côté mais là
encore c'est pas la solution miracle ou
doutez bien par contre le fait de
limiter la consommation de caféine
d'alcool et le fait d'avoir une
alimentation équilibrée ça ça aide à
bien mais en fait la chose la plus
importante à faire c'est déjà de prendre
conscience du problème se rendre compte
qu'on grince des dents la nuit déjà bah
parce que c'est pas facile de régler un
problème quand on n'est pas au courant
qu'on l'a mais aussi parce que ça peut
vous permettre d'être plus vigilante ou
plus vigilante de faire attention et de
vous rendre compte quand vous avez ce
genre de tension pendant la journée et
du coup de relâcher vos mâchoires
d'ailleurs votre dentiste peut aussi
vous donner des trucs pour vous aider à
faire ça et ça peut finir par vous aider
à vous déshabituer à être contracté
comme ça en permanence y compris la nuit
et puis surtout on l'a dit le facteur
numéro 1 de tout ça ça reste le stress
donc tout ce qui vous permettra d'aller
vous coucher moins stressé là ça vous
évitera de commencer des dents l'idée
c'est de lutter contre le stress de
manière globale évidemment mais aussi
d'en remettre une petite couche au
moment d'aller au lit alors oui c'est
plus facile à dire qu'à faire mais c'est
surtout beaucoup moins facile d'y
arriver si on fait rien donc il y a
quand même des trucs qui se tentent déjà
je rappelle pour tout ce qui concerne la
santé mentale donc y compris le stress
l'anxiété etc il y a des gens dont c'est
le métier des psy donc un petit tour
chez le psy c'est toujours une bonne
idée et puis il y a plein d'autres trucs
qui peuvent vous aider là encore l'idée
c'est de trouver la technique qui vous
convient le mieux à vous mais vous avez
l'embarras du choix relaxation hypnose
sophrologie etc c'est à vous de trouver
votre petite night routine si vous
voulez voilà DTC c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez-vous bien et surtout portez-vous
bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]